someone asked me what was the highest
moment during this whole album
priesthood
and i kind of had to stop and think
about it because i'm like we never
really stopped
you know we just kind of keep going and
like david but we love you
we put out a video and we don't even
take the time to enjoy we already moved
on to the next project
you have to wait you can't be like oh
dude people like it we always have to
move on
but i would say the highlight for me was
probably when we were at the galaxy sc
not even winning the award afterwards
preach gave like a very fire speech
and it was really cool to me because
that was not me doing the speech though
who was it my ancestors that was a
spirit hey my spirits also plays
that sphere
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
and that's pretty much what our entire
platform has been about
people said oh you guys are just
starting comments no reason for you to
make videos well we're like you
we're gonna make videos
then we're like we're gonna run our own
shows and sell out a whole weekend at
the comedy works
but we're only two years in people like
that's ridiculous we sold out the whole
entire weekend
you know and then we were putting on
shows where we wouldn't even announce
anybody and we knew people would want to
come because they wanted
they wanted to consume and enjoy what
our vision is
and that moment on stage was a
culmination of that
don't wait for your opportunities take
them where they come and just go for it
so now we're going to put on this gala
because we're not going to wait for
opportunity we're just going to do it
ourselves
and we're excited for the the show that
we're going to put on yeah leave your
comments below tell us
what your favorite moments may have been
and uh
yeah we better see you faces at the
show
that's it